trente huit en dix jours c'est le nombre
de malades ducobu 19 transférés dans des
hôpitaux d'occitanie de bretagne ou
encore de nouvelles aquitaine entre le
13 et le 23 mars selon le ministère de
la santé
parmi ces 38 patients très sont issus de
l'île de france 12 de la région paca et
9 des hôtes france ce dispositif qui
permet de transférer des patients
attendu qu'ovide 19 des hôpitaux engorgé
par l'afflux de malades vers d'autres un
peu moins sollicités à un nom
l'opération chardon elle a été mise en
place l'année dernière lors de la
première vague de l'épidémie de
coronavirus et avait permis le transfert
de 658 patients en réactivant ce
dispositif à la mi mars le gouvernement
espérait pouvoir déplacer une centaine
de patients depuis l'île de france en
une semaine
mais c'était sans compter sur les
difficultés auxquelles se heurte le
dispositif contrairement à la première
opération chardon de mars 2020 l'accord
des familles pour transférer un patient
et cette fois si nécessaire et les
services hospitaliers font face à de
nombreux refus
le plus difficile c'est l'accord des
familles sur les cinq patients que nous
pouvions transféré nous n'avons eu qu'un
seul accord c'est vraiment très
difficile de demander aux familles qui
ont proche entre la vie et la mort en
réanimation de l'envoyer à 500 km pour
eux c'est impossible d'accepter ça et on
les comprend outre le refus des familles
le déplacement du patient est aussi
conditionnée par son état de santé il
doit être suffisamment stable pour
permettre un transfert sanitaire ces
patients éligibles représente à peine
plus de 10% des malades actuellement
hospitalisé en réanimation selon le
directeur général de l'ap-hp de critères
qu il est donc difficile de réunir nous
sommes dans l'impossibilité à la fois de
trouver des patients éligibles
c'est à dire dans un état relativement
stable afin de respecter des conditions
de sécurité de ce transport et dont les
familles acceptent d'évacuation vers une
autre région
conséquence faute d'un nombre de
patients suffisant le tgv
dick alizés prévue le 18 mars dernier a
été annulée s'il devait notamment
permettre de transférer des patients en
provenance d'île de france selon le
ministère de la santé plus de 1400
malades du copic 19 sont actuellement en
réanimation en ile-de-france et le taux
d'incidence lui frôle les 600 cas pour
100000 habitants
une situation jugée préoccupante mais
pour l'heure le transfert massif de
patients ne semble plus d'actualité